we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P you can call the
voicemail any time of day any day you
want the Eggman call then this is sort
of funny the Eggman seems to have been
convinced by urine drinker Christopher
key on Tuesday's show this is funny
hey I think you are a little bit hard on
Christopher key yesterday
I drink my urine seasoned with Nesquik
powder there one glass Two Scoops in
this quick it's almost like a chocolatey
lemon Shake it's perfect unless it's
fresh right out of the spicket then no
seasoning needed but it's a really hard
trick leaning back like that it's called
the bubbler
Shalom all right so the uh the Eggman of
course is joking but I have not gotten
this sort of reaction to any interview
that we've done for a really long time
people disgusted excited titillated
unable to stop laughing people wrote to
me saying they listened to this uh
during that interview the the
Christopher key interview while they
were driving to work in the morning and
had to pull over from laughter
particularly when I said I had him uh
spotted more as a manuka honey guy for
sweetening the urine rather than Stevia
but anyway that'll be a conversation for
a different day on sweeteners wild stuff
without a doubt we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we will talk
about Rudy Giuliani being hit with yet
another lawsuit how many are there at
this point uh we also will discuss
Montana becoming the first U.S state to
ban Tick-Tock and we will talk about the
latest Revelations related to gnome
Chomsky and Jeffrey Epstein they are
becoming of concern to many in our
audience all of those stories and more
on the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad join the money making on the
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com I
will see you then or tomorrow on the
Friday show